testé et approuvé les élus de saint
quentin en yvelines ont inauguré le
nouveau service cailletière mobility 300
stations réparties sur les différentes
communes de l'agglomération et environ
1000 trottinette dès le mois de mai on
innove sur la troisième génération de
trottinettes qui est très numérique
d'ailleurs qui est beaucoup plus facile
à contrôler et à garer
à utiliser l'idée en tout cas à terme ce
qu'on souhaiterait c'est pouvoir
l'ouvrir aux entreprises là on est sur
le domaine public
on travaille avec les villes avec
l'agglomération mais pourquoi pas les
entreprises demain pourquoi pas les
collèges avec le département pourquoi
pas les lycées avec la région une
première phase d'expérimentation
renouvelables sur 12 mois
l'entreprise tire mobility couvre déjà
l'île de france avec 6000 trottinette en
activité sur la région pourtant saint
quentin en yvelines est un nouveau défi
pour l'opérateur
c'est la première fois qu'un opérateur
se se développe en deuxième couronne
donc pour nous vraiment c'était c'était
l'opportunité d'expérimenter sur un
nouveau type de territoire on trouve que
c'est une solution qui très intéressante
pour le dernier kilomètre utile pour les
trajets courts des saint quentinois
les trottinettes s'ajoute en complément
des nouveaux circuits vélo dans
l'agglomération pour les tarifs ils ont
été réfléchies selon une logique
territoriale
vous avez eu toute une gamme en fait
d'offre commerciale en fonction des
publics
il ya même une offre à destination des
personnes à mobilité réduite qui va
pouvoir se développer avec la start-up
omni il ya des différents types de
tarifs donc on a des tarifs étudiants
qu'on va lancer en septembre
on a aussi un tarif solidaire qui sont
pour ceux qui ont des revenus plus bas
qui ont accès à différents avantages
nous pourrons aussi avoir des avantages
sur les trottinettes électriques quant
aux usagers ponctuels
ils pourront débloquer la trottinette
pour un euro le tarif évolue ensuite de
15 centimes d'euros par minute
d'utilisation en cas d'adoption par les
saint quentinois
la société est prête à déployer jusqu'à
2500 trottinette sur le territoire